oh hello welcome to my creative desk I
say creative because it's just extremely
messy and this is where I do a lot of my
projects so welcome I want to talk to
you today about 3d printing because I
tried my very first time to do a 3d
print and it came out tiny all right so
today I will be painting this little 3d
print so I made this in Maya and it's
based off a little wick from a youtube
video called the wig of evil if you
haven't checked it out I will put a link
to it so I made this 3d model it looks
kind of strange at the moment doesn't it
because it's not painted it's just all
one color I'm just gonna paint it with
my acrylics see how that works out
before I do that though how I made this
3d print was with a 3d model that I have
made in my - oh wow I just kind of did
it really rough because I just wanted to
make a 3d model just any 3d model - then
3d print and just try it out take what I
learned about 3d modeling for 3d
printing is that the flat of the base
the easier it will be to create the
actual 3d print as you can tell mine's
actually not that flat because of the
bits of hair so actually that made it
quite difficult
I had to sand it down quite a lot so the
3d models are printed from the bottom to
the top so don't forget that don't add
any random extrusions or it won't be
able to make them very well however if
you need this such as maybe arms on the
side or something like that if you're
going to do a character creature then
you can use support beams that can be
added in and then snapped off afterwards
I made it in Maya and then I put it
through a software called cura which
comes with the 3d printer which is an
Ultimaker then let's just left it for
three hours when I came back this little
guy was waiting for me and I was super
super happy oh wait Helen malaya it did
not look like this I had to file it down
a lot different files spongy files nail
files
though the files to make it look a bit
more defined all the little eyebrows and
things because the eyes didn't actually
3d print very well but I'm still super
happy with with how it turned out let's
try and paint it and see how and there
you have it your very own painted 3d
model I'm quite proud of this the
critics work and I'm not trying to say
that I am the best at painting because
I'm certainly not
I'm just so messy as well but it works
and if I can do this you can certainly
do it as long as you've got access to a
3d printer if you look for your nearest
hack space or something like that they
might have a 3d printer for you to play
around with I'll leave some links in the
description below of all the tools that
I used to create this 3d model I'll also
leave some links in there maybe of
tutorials and things like that if you're
interested in learning how to create
3d model and then create a 3d print from
that 3d model cuz I'm still learning
myself I just thought I'd show you what
I managed to do I hope you enjoyed this
hope you like him
please be awake but it doesn't matter
right have a lovely day or evening
today I thought we'd make something very
simple in Maya 3d modeling together
let's make a ladder because as you can
see I've got a boat here I don't know if
you can see this appropriate it's
supposed to be about